was donald trump jetzt macht denn wenn
man sich das anschaut in bei twitter
gerade in diesen stunden was donald
trump dort bietet für mich wirkt das
fast ein bisschen weiner licht heißt
nicht mehr der donald trump der
überzeugt ist dass er das ding
herumreißt er nörgelt hier er nörgelt da
er wein ein bisschen dort ist es ein
bisschen viel mimimi habe ich das gefühl
von daher meine frage du hast gute
kontakte ins weiße haus unter anderem
zurück dem ehemaligen botschafter hier
in berlin was hört man dann stellen die
sich stellen sie sich stumm oder gibt es
da immer noch im internen zirkel
zumindest aussagen dass sie das ding
noch rumreißen können japan also du hast
deswegen gesagt wie der wahlsieger es
ist noch nicht klar der wahlverlierer
und das ist auch die sicht im weißen
haus und das ist das was man in den
letzten monaten immer wieder betont hat
ist der wahlverlierer sind auf jeden
fall ganz klar die umfrageinstitute die
einen vollkommen anderen wahlausgang
prognostiziert haben als dieses
herzschlagfinale fotofinish wie man im
pferdesport sagen würde dass wir jetzt
gerade erleben eine beobachtung dass
donald trump da nicht mehr allzu
siegesgewisse auf twitter erscheint und
die sozusagen diese stimmung des real
donald trump ihnen in den letzten vier
jahren erlebt haben dass die ein wenig
erloschen ist dass dieser kampfgeist ein
wenig erlaubnis das kann man durchaus
sagen dass teile ich wenn man sich
besonders an schaut das und twitter ist
daher ein faszinierendes phänomen
twitter hat ist von donald trump benutzt
worden wie von keinem us präsidenten
er geht sofort tatsächlich als
instrument des regierens und wenn man
sich jetzt anschaut wie sich auf twitter
dass unterstützer feld von donald trump
verhält dann ist es da derzeit
tatsächlich bemerkenswert ruhig und dann
sind es tatsächlich konservative
konservative analysten konservative
journalisten die in den letzten zwei
drei jahren verlässlich das intoniert
und das retweetet haben was donald trump
auf twitter geäußert haben die jetzt auf
einmal da eine teilweise doch deutlich
andere sichtweise einnehmen also das was
wir aus dem weißen haus vernehmen ist
derzeit
tendenziell eher eine man kann sagen
vielleicht ratlose still aber man muss
noch eine sache sagen die ganz ganz
wichtig ist natürlich weiß man im weißen
haus dass dieser kampf um die letzten
staaten dieser passte victory jetzt ganz
sicher nicht beschritten wird auf
twitter ist nicht ganz klar ob der
us-präsident das weiß aber im umfeld von
donald trump in seinem beraterstab weiß
man das natürlich dass twitter kein pass
to victory sondern der pastor victory
führt jetzt entweder durch einen das
muss man sagen zu diesem zeitpunkt
durchaus überraschen sie in pennsylvania
north carolina und dann bräuchte donald
trump immer noch einen weiteren staat
nevada haben wir gerade gehörte
zunehmend unwahrscheinlich wisconsin
wird schon in rikon verlangt michigan in
der schwebe aber bräuchte jetzt
tatsächlich noch vier staaten die
penselin heraus carolina georgia und
dann noch einen weiteren für diesen pass
to victory und deswegen kann man sagen
dass der zweite path to victory den das
weiße haus das hat man ja gestern in der
rede von donald trump ganz klar gehört
das hat er ganz eindeutig gesagt den das
weiße haus sieht führt durch den supreme
court und das wird natürlich eine
ideologisch hochspannende hochbrisante
und hoch dramatische auseinandersetzung
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren